aux premières lueurs de l'aurore le
bateau de pêche de pascual arrive au
port de fiumicino près de rome
après une nuit de chalutage dans les
eaux profondes de la méditerranée loin
de la peur de la pandémie de coronavirus
les pêcheurs remettent leur masque à la
proche des côtes italiennes
le 11 mars dernier le gouvernement
italien a déclaré la fermeture nationale
des commerces non essentiels pour tenter
notamment de contrôler la propagation du
virus
une décision qui a directement impacté
l'activité de pascual vous pouvez faire
le calcul tout a chuté de 50% à la fois
l'offre et la demande également sur nos
revenus
avant je sors tes péchés 5 me par
semaine maintenant à cause de la
pandémie due couronne un virus nous
pouvons sortir que trois fois par
semaine même constat du côté de la criée
si les acheteurs venus portent masques
et gants de protection et respectent les
distances de sécurité
l'activité a tout de même
considérablement ralenti c'est une
situation particulièrement dramatique
que nous vivons en ce moment notre
secteur subit de lourdes pertes au cours
de cette période nous avons dû réduire
les ventes à la criée à trois fois par
semaine
le prix a chuté de manière significative
au cours des premiers jours de
quarantaine et nous avons vu qu'il y
avait de moins en moins de demandes
les ventes sont principalement destinées
aux supermarchés et aux poissonniers
en temps normal la jetée du port est
bondée de monde depuis le début du
confinement seulement quelques pêcheurs
y viennent quotidiennement pour
réfectionner leur bateau